[Música]
economía en directo américa me
acompañando el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches ya lo
mencionamos en el informativo la visita
de vladimir putin a la república
islámica de irán como puede entonces
comparar estos dos países en materia
energética
santiago es un tema bastante complejo
porque tanto rusia como irán son
productores de petróleo y gas en ese
mercado son competencia porque sus
principales clientes en común son india
y china pero todo parece indicar que lo
que los une que es esa mala relación con
occidente los está llevando a la
cooperación coincidiendo con la visita
de vladimir putin la compañía nacional
de petróleo de irán y la rusa gazprom
firmaron un memorándum de entendimiento
por valor de unos 40 mil millones de
dólares gazprom ayudará a irán a
desarrollar dos yacimientos de gas y
seis de petróleo además de participar en
proyectos de gas natural licuado y en la
construcción de gasoductos de
exportación pasemos ahora a hablar del
fondo monetario internacional que
advirtió precisamente las consecuencias
que puede haber en europa ante un
posible corte del gas procedente de
rusia y es que de producirse este corte
los países más dependientes podrían caer
su producto interno bruto en torno a un
6 por ciento mientras que en alemania
considerado el motor económico de la
unión europea el producto interno bruto
caería cerca de un 3% en caso de un
cierre total del gas ruso según el
reporte del fbi los países más afectados
serían en este orden hungría eslovaquia
república checa italia alemania austria
rumanía eslovenia croacia polonia y los
países bajos los primeros 4 países son
los que experimentarían una caída de la
actividad económica de alrededor del 6%
de su producto interno bruto una fuente
de gazprom dijo que se va a reanudar el
envío de nor string 1 este jueves pero
que sería en un menor flujo ya veremos
qué pasa entonces jorge pasamos ahora
hablar de ese paro de transportadores en
perú siguen allí paralizados los
transportes la defensoría del pueblo
reportó este lunes bloqueos en
carreteras en la sureña región de
ayacucho y también manifestaciones o
manifestantes en el primer día del paro
indefinido de transportistas de carga y
agricultores que protestan por el alza
de los precios de los combustibles y los
fertilizantes ese país tiene la gasolina
más cara de toda latinoamérica según un
reporte de bloomberg lo que hace que los
peruanos busquen otras alternativas
abastecer sus vehículos nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
nos amplía esta información
luis alcántara fabrica muebles de acero
y en sus ratos libres es taxista sin
embargo debido al elevado precio de la
gasolina ha decidido modificar su carro
a gas natural vehicular para poder
seguir generando ingresos como conductor
para tudela presenta critica por eso ya
con cambiando legal la mayoría se borra
para algunos que también viven del taxi
no hay peor debe ser yo que tengo tu
trabajo
haití va a ir también pataleando ya poco
a poco ya la que tú éstos pasen así como
louis muchos peruanos se están
recurriendo a la conversión de sus
vehículos de gasolina a gas natural
aprovechando un financiamiento estatal
sin intereses eso permitirá a los
usuarios un ahorro mensual de cerca del
70%
según la asociación de estaciones de
servicio en el último año los precios de
las gasolinas de 91 venta y 5 octanos
han subido 35 y 47 por ciento
respectivamente las causas del
sobreprecio impuestos elevados una
onerosa cadena de comercialización y los
altos costos de producción de las
refinerías subir el combustible sube
todo porque todo se transporta
con algo que gaste combustible y acá
pagamos los sueldos millonarios de los
funcionarios de petroperú y sus coimas
en todo lo que compra eso es lo que
estamos pagando por eso pagamos de
combustible más caro de sudamérica según
los analistas el elevado precio de la
gasolina repercutirá negativamente a
largo plazo en la economía peruana ese
aumento muy fuerte del precio de los
combustibles
obviamente está haciendo que la
inflación suba fuertemente y golpe más a
los que menos tienen por qué porque los
sectores de bajos ingresos más del 50
por ciento de su gasto diario lo
destinan a alimentos y combustibles
el estado ha destinado más de 630
millones de dólares en exoneraciones
tributarias y subsidios en un intento de
combatir el alza de los combustibles no
obstante diversos agentes económicos
prevén que durante julio los precios
seguirán altos y que la inflación
alcanzará el 9% y para el cierre
hablamos de netflix que brindó su
reporte del tercer trimestre perdió
muchos suscriptores pero la compañía
creció jorge así que con el foco en
netflix está desde abril pasado cuando
anunció que perdió 200.000 suscriptores
en el primer trimestre de este año y que
esperaba perder 2 millones en el segundo
la compañía perdió ahora un millón de
suscriptores entre abril y junio la
mitad de lo que había previsto world
suite en parte por el estreno de la
nueva temporada de stranger thing su
serie más popular pero sus ingresos han
crecido un 9% unos 7.900 millones de
dólares netflix también mando a revisión
su modelo de negocios despidió unos 450
empleados se anunció un nuevo nivel de
suscripción más barato pero abierto a la
publicidad ha dicho que su talón de
aquiles es el uso compartido de las
contraseñas jorge muchas gracias por
este reporte el mundo económico es todo
por el momento aquí en directo américa a
continuación el debate
[Música]